THE 14 FINALISTS
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HAVE WEATHERED
THE TOUGHEST COMPETITION YET.
THREE GIRLS HAVE SURVIVED,
AND TONIGHT ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
WILL BE NAMED
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
KAHLEN, A SMALL TOWN GIRL
FROM OKLAHOMA,
CAME INTO THIS COMPETITION
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO EXPERIENCE.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
NO.
BUT RIGHT FROM THE START
SHE KNEW HOW TO WORK IT
WITH HER WALK
AND IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
CONFIDENCE ISSUES HAVE PLAGUED
HER THROUGHOUT THE COMPETITION.
YOU DON'T WANT ME,
'CAUSE I CAN'T DANCE.
YOU'RE NOT ROCKING MY WORLD
IN FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW.
WE GOT A LITTLE SOMEONE
TO WORK WITH YOU.
KAHLEN, THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
THAT YOU WERE A VERY PRETTY GIRL
BUT HE NOTICED YOUR LACK
OF CONFIDENCE RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
YOU'RE STILL GETTING
VERY NERVOUS.
I NOTICED YOUR NECK
WENT BRIGHT RED AND SPLOTCHY.
KAHLEN NEEDS TO PROVE
TO THE JUDGES THAT SHE
BELIEVES IN HERSELF ENOUGH
TO TAKE IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
NAIMA, THE REFORMED PARTY GIRL
FROM DETROIT,
ARRIVED IN LOS ANGELES
EMBRACING HER NEW QUIET,
DIGNIFIED SELF.
MY PARENTS DIVORCED
SO I TOTALLY GOT INTO
THE PARTY SCENE.
THERE WAS JUST SO MANY THINGS
I WAS CARRYING AROUND
FROM MY PAST, MY CHILDHOOD,
AND MY MOHAWK HAS HELPED
TO CENTER THOSE THOUGHTS.
NAIMA'S UNIQUE LOOK--
MY MOM IS BLACK AND IRISH
AND MY FATHER IS MEXICAN
AND BLACK.
AND NEW-FOUND FOCUS
AND DETERMINATION
HAVE HELPED HER
WITH CHALLENGE AFTER CHALLENGE.
OUR WINNER TODAY IS NAIMA.
NAIMA.
NAIMA NOW NEEDS TO FIGURE OUT
THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN KEEPING IT TOGETHER
AND KEEPING IT ALL INSIDE.
I SEE SOMETHING
THAT'S MUFFLING
ALL THE REAL STUFF BEHIND YOU.
CAN NAIMA FIND A WAY
TO MAKE HER PERSONALITY POP?
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THE COMPETITION,
KEENYAH WAS CONFIDENT
AND HUNGRY FOR SUCCESS.
BUT SOMETIMES
SHE LET HER CONFIDENCE
TURN INTO ARROGANCE.
I MEAN, I HAVE NO CHOICE
TO DO WHAT YOU SAY.
BUT IT'S NOT
WHAT I WANT TO DO.
I MEAN, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT BOTH J., MYSELF AND TYRA
SAT DOWN AND TALKED ABOUT.
THE SHEER DETERMINATION
HAS HELPED KEENYAH
KEEP HER EYES ON THE PRIZE.
THE WINNER IS KEENYAH.
BUT PROBLEMS WITH HER FIGURE
HAVE EATEN AWAY AT HER
OVER TIME.
GIRLFRIEND, YOU NEED
TO LOSE SOME WEIGHT.
WILL KEENYAH'S APPETITE
FOR VICTORY CONVINCE THE JUDGES
THAT SHE CAN LOOK THE PART
OF A TOP MODEL?
FIND OUT TONIGHT
IN THE SEASON FINALE.
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
♪♪♪
OH, LOOK.
HELLO, LITTLE GUYS.
YOU THINK IT
CAN ATTACK ME?
I DON'T KNOW.
LOOK AT THOSE BEAKS.
IT'S DOWN TO THE LAST THREE,
AND YOU REALLY HAVE TO JUST
PROVE THAT YOU WANT TO BE HERE
AND WORK YOUR HARDEST.
COME ON, GUYS.
BYE, GUYS.
NICE MEETING YOU.
LOOK AT HIS FACE.
REMEMBER THIS FACE.
WITH JUST A FEW DAYS LEFT
IN THE COMPETITION--
HI, MISS KAHLEN.
I WANTED TO TALK TO EACH
OF THE GIRLS ONE ON ONE.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
NO.
NO?
SO HOW IS IT GOING IN THE HOUSE
AND JUST THE WHOLE COMPETITION?
COMING INTO THIS COMPETITION
THERE WAS A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
DIDN'T BELIEVE I COULD DO THIS.
I'VE HEARD JUST,
"YOU'RE NOT GIRLIE ENOUGH,"
OR "YOU'RE NOT TALL ENOUGH."
"THERE'S NOTHING UNIQUE
ABOUT YOU."
I USED TO HAVE FRIENDS
THAT WOULD LOOK AT ME
LIKE I WAS CRAZY
SAYING THAT I WANTED TO MODEL.
WELL, IT'S, YOU KNOW,
MODELING IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE
ALWAYS WANTED, AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S STAYED WITH ME.
SO--AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I AM DRIVEN TO DO
AND I'M GONNA DO IT NO MATTER
WHAT PEOPLE TELL ME TO DO.
HI, TYRA.
SO WHAT'S UP, MISS NAIMA?
LIKE, I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH
ABOUT MYSELF BEING HERE.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED
ABOUT YOURSELF?
I FEEL COMFORT WITH MYSELF.
I FEEL ACCEPTANCE.
LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT I WENT
THROUGH AND JUST THAT HATE
AND JUST, LIKE, I HATE MY BODY,
I HATE MY FACE,
I HATE MYSELF.
NOW, I DON'T HAVE ROOM
TO HATE MYSELF.
I DON'T HAVE ROOM
TO DEAL WITH THAT ANYMORE.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT
A COMPETITION THAT IS SO MUCH
ABOUT CRITIQUE AND INSECURITY
IS GIVING YOU SELF-ESTEEM.
'CAUSE A LOT OF TIMES,
THE OPPOSITE HAPPENS
DURING THIS COMPETITION.
RIGHT NOW IT REALLY IS
EVERY MAN FOR HIMSELF.
I DON'T WANT TO HELP ANYBODY
WITH ANYTHING
THAT CAN SIGNIFICANTLY PLACE
THEM A STEP ABOVE ME.
HOW DO YOU FIND THE MODELING
EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF BODY
AND FOOD AND THE PRESSURE?
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU EAT
OUT OF STRESS?
I PROBABLY HAVE TO SAY
SOMETIMES IT'S AN ORAL FIXATION.
I HAVE TO REALLY ASK MYSELF
EVERY TIME I GO TO, LIKE, EAT
SOMETHING, LIKE, "AM I HUNGRY,
OR DO I JUST WANT TO TASTE
SOMETHING THAT TASTES GOOD?"
IT'S FUNNY,
BECAUSE WITH MYSELF,
LIKE, I REALIZED THAT I COULDN'T
FOLLOW THE RULES
OF THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
AND I HAD TO RE-ROUTE MY CAREER.
BUT I WAS FORTUNATE TO DO THAT,
BECAUSE I WAS ALREADY
A SUPERMODEL
IN THE FASHION WORLD.
I HAD THE LUXURY OF SWITCHING
FROM HIGH FASHION
TO MORE MAINSTREAM MODELING.
YOU'RE NEW, SO YOU DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK EATING HEALTHY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WHETHER YOU'RE GONNA BE
A TOP MODEL OR NOT.
YOU SHOULD WORK
ON BEING HEALTHY.
I THINK YOU SHOULD FOCUS
ON THAT, MISS KEENYAH.
GIVE ME A HUG.
SO GLAD I COULD TALK
TO YOU LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW IT'S DOUBLE JEOPARDY.
YOU'LL NEED TO DRAW ON
EVERYTHING YOU'VE LEARNED
TO GET THROUGH THE DAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT,
SO DUCK FOR COVER AT 6:45 A.M."
WE HAVE TO DRAW DUCKS, GUYS.
GREAT.
ALL RIGHT, SO ARE YOU GIRLS
READY FOR A RUNWAY SHOW?
YES.
I AM REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE I'M VERY COMFORTABLE
ON THE RUNWAY.
I'VE GOT THIS ONE IN THE BAG.
ACTUALLY, TODAY WE ARE NOT
DOING A RUNWAY SHOW.
YOU GIRLS ARE DOING
A COMMERCIAL.
UH-OH, COMMERCIALS?
ACTING IS NOT MY THING AT ALL.
WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING
A COMMERCIAL FOR COVER GIRL.
NEW COVER GIRL OUTLAST MAKEUP,
IT'S THE FIRST OF ITS KIND.
IT'S A LONG-LASTING FOUNDATION.
THEY'VE MADE IT SO EASY.
IT'S A TWO-STEP FORMULA, AND IT
MAKES YOUR SKIN LOOK BEAUTIFUL
ALL DAY LONG IN ANY CONDITIONS.
SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IS WE'RE GONNA HAVE A COMMERCIAL
THAT STARTS OFF SHOWING
A RUNWAY SHOW HAPPENING.
AND THEN WE CUT TO BACKSTAGE
WHERE EVERYTHING IS CRAZY--
THE HAIR IS FALLING APART,
THE DRESS MIGHT SNAP,
THE BEADS MIGHT COME OFF.
WE'RE GONNA SHOOT
A FULL 30-SECOND COMMERCIAL.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO A PRINT
CAMPAIGN IN THE SAME DAY.
WE'VE GOT AN AMAZING DIRECTOR
AND PHOTOGRAPHER HERE TODAY.
THIS IS RUSSEL YOUR DIRECTOR
AND HELMUT YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
SO WE'RE JUST GONNA TRY
A BUNCH OF OUTFITS
AND WE'LL JUST FIGURE OUT
WHAT EACH GIRL'S WEARING.
IT IS VERY HARD FOR ME
TO JUST SIT THERE
AND TRY AND MEMORIZE IT
WHILE ALL THIS OTHER STUFF
IS GOING ON AROUND ME.
ARE YOU UP FIRST?
OH, I FORGOT
I HAD LINES TO MEMORIZE.
GOING INTO THE SHOOTS I'M REALLY
NERVOUS, AND I'M NOT CONFIDENT
WITH HOW IT MIGHT TURN OUT.
I DON'T WANT
THE REASON FOR ME GOING HOME
BEING MY CONFIDENCE.
I FEEL LIKE IF THE MODEL
HAS, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE AND SHE CAN,
YOU KNOW, STAND UP FOR HERSELF,
IT DOESN'T MATTER
HOW PEOPLE TREAT HERE, YOU KNOW?
THE THING ABOUT ME
THAT THE PANEL SHOULD CONSIDER
OVER NAIMA AND KAHLEN
IS THAT PERSONALITY-WISE
I'LL BE A GREAT REPRESENTATIVE
FOR ANYTHING THAT'S OUT
IN THE MODEL INDUSTRY.
YOU ALWAYS LOOK
REALLY SERIOUS.
REALLY?
I MEAN, I KNOW YOU'RE QUIET.
NOT QUIET,
MYSTERIOUS.
THE PANEL CONSIDERS MY WEAKNESS
IS NOT BEING ABLE TO OPEN UP
COMPLETELY IN FRONT OF THEM.
THE JUDGES STILL SAY
THEY DON'T KNOW NAIMA.
LAST PANEL, IF I WAS NOT
ON THAT CHOPPING BLOCK,
THEN I WOULD NOT HAVE TO TRY
AND PINPOINT WHAT IS REALLY
MAKING ME FEEL LIKE
I CAN'T SHOW MYSELF TO PEOPLE.
WHO'S GOING HOME?
YOU KNOW, AT THIS POINT,
WHO CAN SAY?
AND ACTION!
NAIMA, BE CAREFUL
NOT TO LEAD WITH YOUR CHIN.
'CAUSE WHEN IT GOES UP,
THE CAMERA GOES UP
IN YOUR NOSTRILS AND WE CAN SEE
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING.
I AM ROCKING IT.
IT'S ONLY TWO OTHER GIRLS
THAT ARE MY COMPETITION,
SO I HAVE TO BLOW THEM OUT
OF THE WATER.
I NOTICED A SLIGHT
ATTITUDE CHANGE IN KEENYAH.
I THINK THAT SHE'S FEELING
A LITTLE BIT MORE ARROGANT.
KEENYAH GOT TO THE END OF
THE RUNWAY AND THEN SHE'D WINK,
AND SHE WINKED AND SHE WINKED.
IT STARTED LOOKING REHEARSED--
GET TO THEN END, TURN, WINK.
IT DIDN'T SEEM NATURAL ANYMORE.
ACTION!
IT WAS JUST SO AMAZING
SHOOTING THE BACKSTAGE CHAOTIC
SCENES, AND IT IS TOTAL MADNESS.
I'M SO NERVOUS
ABOUT THE COMMERCIAL,
JUST DELIVERING THE LINES
EXACTLY VERBATIM.
TWO STEPS NOW
TO ALL-DAY WOW.
ONE.
THE PREP STEP.
BRING THE VIEWER IN, LIKE,
"HEY, I'M TALKING TO YOU."
OKAY.
ONE, TWO.
MAKEUP MELTDOWN?
NOT ON THIS FACE.
TWO STEPS--OUTLAST.
CHECK OUT THE NEW STEP.
TWO-STEP OUTLAST MAKEUP.
IT'S THE FRESH WORD
IN MAKEUP.
IT'S A LIVING HELL FOR ME.
I'M NOT A MEMORIZER.
I'VE NEVER
HAVE BEEN ONE.
A COVER GIRL'S LIFE
CAN SEEM--
COVER GIRL--
MAKEUP MELTDOWN--
I'M SORRY.
A COVER GIRL'S LIFE CAN SEEM--
MILK UP MAKE--
MILK UP?
OKAY, CAN I START OVER?
MAKEUP MELTDOWN
BECAME MILKSHAKE.
ONE STEP NOW TO ALL-DAY--
JEEZ LOUIS-US.
I ALREADY FORGOT THE LINES.
AND IT'S JUST
SO MUCH AT ONE TIME THAT I'M
JUST KIND OF GOING CRAZY
AND JUST LOST IT ALL.
IT WAS TERRIBLE FOR ME.
ME, TOO.
TO ME, MAKEUP MELTDOWN
WAS SOMETHING, LIKE,
I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
SO, TODAY, NOT ONLY
WERE WE DOING A COMMERCIAL
BUT WE'RE ALSO DOING A BEAUTY
SHOT FOR COVER GIRL.
YOU KNOW BEAUTY SHOTS
ARE THE MOST DIFFICULT.
BE YOU.
IF YOU CAN BE YOU IN THE CAMERA,
THAT'S A COVER GIRL SHOT.
A BEAUTY SHOT IS BASICALLY
A VERY TIGHT FRAME ON THE FACE,
AND IT'S JUST TO REVEAL
YOUR NATURAL BEAUTY.
I FEEL LIKE A HAND, A HAND,
A HAND, A HEAD, A HEAD.
JUST WORK IT IN THROUGH THERE.
AND DON'T LOSE YOUR NECK.
IT IS A LOT OF PRESSURE
DOING A COVER GIRL COSMETICS
COMMERCIAL, BECAUSE THIS COULD
POSSIBLY BE MY FUTURE EMPLOYER.
KEENYAH GAVE ME
THE RIGHT SMILE,
BUT IT JUST GOT STUCK THERE.
IMAGINE THAT THING WHEN YOU
GET TO THE END OF THE RUNWAY,
AND THERE'S A CERTAIN ENERGY
THAT'S THERE.
MOST OF THE PHOTO SHOOTS
THAT WE DID BEFORE
WERE KIND OF FIERCE.
FOR COVER GIRL,
IT'S JUST SMILE AND BE HAPPY.
THAT'S A LOT HARDER.
NAIMA, SOMETHING LIKE THIS
IS SO WIDE I NEED IT TO BE
A LITTLE MORE LIKE--
EXACTLY, BEAUTIFUL.
THIS IS A MAKE-OR-BREAK
SHOOT FOR ME TODAY.
I NEED TO HAVE MY PHOTOGRAPHS
COME OUT VERY WELL.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS,
BUT I NEVER GIVE UP.
BELLISSIMA.
I DID SO HORRIBLE
WITH THE COVER GIRL COMMERCIAL.
THE BEAUTY SHOT IS GIVING ME
A CHANCE TO REDEEM MYSELF.
IT'S A VERY TIGHT SHOT, SO
YOU NEED LITTLE POSES LIKE THIS,
A LITTLE COY, A LITTLE SMILE.
GOT IT.
I DO KIND OF TRANSFORM WHEN
I GET IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
'CAUSE IT GIVES ME A CHANCE
TO SHOW MY GIRLIE SIDE.
HEY, KAHLEN, YOU CAN GIVE ME
LITTLE SMALLER CHANGES
LIKE BAM, BAM.
BAM, BAM.
BAM.
OKAY, GIVE ME A BAM.
BAM, A GIGGLE.
COME ON, KAHLEN.
KEEP IT GIGGLING.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF YOU
HAVE TO FART, BUT YOU'RE GONNA
SMILE AT THE SAME TIME.
PRETTY, LOOK.
LOOK, FART AND GIGGLE WORKED.
GOOD JOB, KAHLEN.
IT'S A WRAP.
IT'S A WRAP, YES.
HEY.
YOU DIDN'T SEE THIS TYRA MAIL?
"TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TWO OF YOU WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL
BE ELIMINATED."
I FEEL LIKE MY COMPETITION
RIGHT NOW IS PROBABLY NAIMA,
BECAUSE THE JUDGES
SEE SOMETHING SPECIAL IN HER
THAT I REALLY DON'T SEE.
I HAVE FELT THAT I NEED
TO PUT ON A FRONT
FOR THE JUDGES
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
THROUGHOUT THE COMPETITION.
BUT I REALIZED
WHAT THE JUDGES WANTED WAS ME.
I THINK THAT KAHLEN
IS STRUGGLING A LOT.
SHE HAS BEEN SLIDING
IN THE PAST TWO WEEKS
WHEN IT COMES TO HER PHOTOS.
THE PHOTOGRAPHS DON'T EVEN
MATTER THAT MUCH ANYMORE.
IT'S MORE ABOUT PERFORMANCE.
MY PERFORMANCE WASN'T
OUTSTANDING AT ALL.
I THINK
FOR TOMORROW'S ELIMINATION
I'M THE ONE GOING HOME.
WELCOME, LADIES.
WOW, THE FINAL THREE.
WELL, NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE OUR
12TH CUT, WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW YOU GUYS KNOW
ABOUT THESE PRIZES.
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THEM
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
FROM TOP INTERNATIONAL MODEL
MANAGEMENT COMPANY--
FORD MODELS--
A PHOTO SPREAD IN "ELLE"
MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER, GILLES BESIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
FROM COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OUR JUDGES, OF COURSE--
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS,
NIGEL BARKER
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
NOLé MARIN PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST
AND GRETHA SCHOLTZ.
GRETHA IS THE DESIGNER
OF POISON IVY,
WHICH IS AN AMAZING
BATHING SUIT LINE
HERE IN SOUTH AFRICA.
THE TWO GIRLS LEFT STANDING
AT THE END OF THE NIGHT,
WILL BE THE TWO GIRLS WALKING IN
THE ULTIMATE RUNWAY FASHION SHOW
WITH THREE OF CAPE TOWN'S
TOP FASHION DESIGNERS--
GRETHA'S POISON IVY LINE
BEING ONE OF THEM.
CAN I BE IN THE SHOW, PLEASE?
PLEASE?
TONIGHT,
YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED
ON THREE DIFFERENT THINGS--
THE FIRST IS THE COMMERCIAL
FROM COVER GIRL COSMETICS,
THE NEXT IS YOUR RUNWAY WALK,
AND THE LAST IS YOUR PHOTO FROM
YOUR COVER GIRL PHOTO SHOOT.
SO YOU GUYS DID A COMMERCIAL
AND HERE IT IS.
A COVER GIRL'S LIFE
IS A FRANTIC PACE
AND WILL MAKE YOU FEEL
LIKE A RACE.
MAKEUP MELTDOWN?
NOT ON THIS FACE.
ONLY FROM COVER GIRL--
NEW OUTLAST MAKEUP.
TWO STEPS NOW--
TO ALL-DAY WOW.
ONE, THE PREP STEP
SMOOTHES THE PORES.
SHINE IS GONE.
TWO, THE MAKEUP STAYS FRESH,
STAYS FLAWLESS,
STAYS ON.
WHILE THE REST OF THE DAY
MAY GO WRONG--
CHECK OUT THE NEW STEP--
TWO-STEP OUTLAST MAKEUP.
IT IS THE FRESH WORD
IN MAKEUP.
AND IT'S ONLY FROM EASY,
BREEZY BEAUTIFUL COVER GIRL.
THAT WAS REALLY COOL.
SO FIRST IS NAIMA.
YOUR BEST, STRONGEST RUNWAY WALK
THAT YOU HAVE LEARNED.
NAIMA,
YOUR LEGS LOOKED GUMBY.
IF THAT'S YOUR SIGNATURE WALK,
I'D CHANGE IT IMMEDIATELY.
ALL RIGHT, NAIMA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
DRUM ROLL, PLEASE.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
OH, WOW.
YOU HAVE A NATURAL SPARK.
THIS PHOTOGRAPH
YOU CAN SEE IN ANY MAGAZINE
FROM "VOGUE" TO "ALLURE"
TO "GLAMOUR."
THIS PHOTOGRAPH IS ROCKIN',
GIRL.
OVER ALL, IT'S A NICE SHOT.
BUT IT'S NOT
SLAM DUNK FOR ME.
SO YOU GUYS DID A COMMERCIAL.
ONLY FROM COVER GIRL
NEW OUTLAST MAKEUP.
NAIMA, I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
YOU WERE THE SPECIAL SPICE
IN THAT COMMERCIAL.
I WASN'T SO SURE
IF YOU COULD PULL IT OFF,
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE EDGY GIRL,
THE MYSTERIOUS GIRL,
BUT YOU LOOK SO COMMERCIAL
AND SO RELATABLE.
I'M, LIKE, SHOCKED
'CAUSE I DIDN'T THINK
YOU COULD DO THIS HONESTLY.
NAIMA, WHY HAVEN'T
WE SEEN THIS ENERGY
OR THIS TYPE OF BEAUTY BEFORE?
I WANTED TO SUPPRESS A PAST
THAT I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND SUPPRESSING THAT ONE THING
INSIDE OF ME, MADE ME SUPPRESS
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT'S THE PAST.
LEARN FROM IT.
IT'S "O" - "V,"
OVER, BABY.
I SEE A COMPLETE JOURNEY
OF A PERSON,
AND I AM REALLY PROUD OF YOU.
ALL RIGHT, KEENYAH,
SO GIVE US A WALK.
I LOVE,
REALLY LOVE, THE ENERGY
YOU'VE BEEN GIVING US,
BUT THE WALK
I THINK NEEDS A BIT WORK.
SO YOU DID A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR COVER GIRL COSMETICS,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
OH, WOW.
IT REALLY WORKS WELL HERE.
YOU LOOK REALLY COMMANDING.
YOU NEED MORE OF A NECK.
TO ME IT'S NOT
A COVER GIRL SHOT.
I ALWAYS DO THAT
SHOULDER ON MY CHIN.
THAT'S, LIKE,
ONE OF MY SIGNATURE MOVES, THE--
WELL, I THINK THAT EVERYONE
WILL DISAGREE ON THE POSE,
BUT I'M GONNA GO STRAIGHT OUT
AND GO BUY SOME COVER GIRL.
WE ALL NEED THAT MAKEUP
TO MAKE US LOOK LIKE THAT.
SO, KEENYAH, WE'RE GONNA
FOCUS ON THE COMMERCIAL NOW.
RUNWAY CAN FEEL LIKE A RACE.
DID YOU GET A SENSE
OF YOUR INNER BEAUTY AT ALL?
IT WAS MEDIOCRE.
WOW, I MUST BE WATCHING
A DIFFERENT COMMERCIAL,
'CAUSE I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THIS IS YOUR FORTE.
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT
NATURAL SMILE.
ALL RIGHT, KEENYAH, THANKS.
THANK YOU.
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, DO YOU HOLD
YOUR BREATH WHEN YOU'RE WALKING?
SOMETIMES
I FORGET TO BREATHE.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT ON THE RUNWAY
THEY'RE STILL CONSTANTLY
TAKING PICTURES OF YOU.
SO EVEN THOUGH YOUR BODY MIGHT
BE DOING ALL THIS FIERCENESS,
IF YOUR FACE IS LIKE,
THAT PICTURE'S NOT GONNA RUN.
KAHLEN, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR COVER GIRL,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
OH, YOU KNOW WHAT,
YOU'VE NEVER LOOKED LIKE THAT.
THAT JUST REEKS COVER GIRL,
BABY GIRL.
KAHLEN, WHERE IS THIS GIRL?
WHY ISN'T THIS SMILE,
LIKE, PLANTED ON YOUR FACE
FROM THE MOMENT YOU WALK IN?
I DON'T KNOW, GUYS.
I DON'T LIKE THIS PICTURE.
I LIKE THE PHOTO.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
A COSMETIC AD TO ME.
I SEE SOMETHING
MY 10-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER
WOULD RUN OUT AND BUY.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT LOOKS LIKE--
INSTEAD OF--
I SEE IT ALL--
A GORGEOUS NOSE, LONG NECK,
BEAUTIFUL SKIN.
ALL RIGHT, KAHLEN, SO YOU HAD
A COMMERCIAL FOR COVER GIRL,
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT YOU.
THE MAKEUP STAYS FRESH,
STAYS FLAWLESS, STAYS ON.
WHAT I LOVED ABOUT YOU
WAS THE LITTLE QUIET MOMENTS
OR THE MOMENTS WHEN YOU WEREN'T
THE ONE FOCUS OF THE CAMERA.
I WAS LOOKING AT YOU.
OVERALL, THOUGH, IT WAS
A LITTLE BIT STALE.
IT HAD NO FLAVOR,
NO PUNCH, NO PIZAZZ.
YOU JUST KIND OF SIT
IN A COMFORTABLE PLACE
RATHER THAN KNOWING TO...
POP.
THANK YOU, GIRLS.
THANK YOU.
NAIMA.
THIS IS GONNA BE
REALLY DIFFICULT.
ALL OF THE GIRLS FOR ME
HAVE DONE EXTREMELY WELL.
I THINK THAT NAIMA,
SHE MANAGED TO DELIVER
THAT SORT OF COVER GIRL SPARKLE.
SHE REALLY
CHANGED MY MIND TODAY
IN THE COVER GIRL COMMERCIAL.
I CAN SEE LITTLE GIRLS
LOOKING AT HER AND BEING LIKE,
"OOH, I LIKE HER."
TODAY, OKAY, SHE CAME OUT
OF HER SHELL
AND SHE'S ABLE TO SMILE.
A MODEL NEEDS
MORE THAN THAT.
KAHLEN.
LOOKING CLOSER,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S SELLING.
SHE ALMOST LOOKS A LITTLE SCARED
SHE ALMOST LOOKS LIKE
LIGHTNING HAS HIT HER.
KAHLEN I THINK
SHE'S GOT THE STUFF TO MAKE IT.
SHE CAN STOMP THAT RUNWAY.
SHE CAN TAKE A GORGEOUS PICTURE,
BUT SHE SCARES THE HELL OUT
OF ME FOR BEING A SPOKESMODEL.
THIS IS NOT A GIRL THAT,
WHEN SHE STANDS IN FRONT OF YOU,
MAKES YOU AWARE OF HER PRESENCE,
AND THAT'S WHAT A COVER GIRL IS.
A COVER GIRL IS A GIRL
THAT WALKS INTO A ROOM
AND YOU ALMOST
WANT TO SORT OF
HEAR A ♪ UH-HUH ♪♪
KEENYAH.
AS FAR AS COVER GIRL GOES,
KEENYAH NAILED COVER GIRL.
I THINK HER COMMERCIAL
WAS VERY GOOD.
SHE'S NOT HIGH FASHION.
NO, SHE'S NOT.
AT ALL.
I AGREE WITH YOU,
BUT THAT'S MY POINT.
MY POINT IS THAT COVER GIRL
IS ONE ASPECT OF THIS.
SHE IS, FOR ME,
THE MOST STRIKING OF THE GIRLS
AT FIRST GLANCE.
KEENYAH NEEDS TO LOSE WEIGHT.
KEENYAH NEEDS
TO LOSE WEIGHT.
KEENYAH NEEDS TO LOSE WEIGHT.
ALL OF THESE GIRLS
HAVE STRENGTHS
AND ALL OF THEM HAVE WEAKNESSES.
BUT THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE.
THAT'S IT.
THREE GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
AND ONE OF YOU VERY SOON WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND TONIGHT, ONE OF YOU
WILL GO HOME.
WE FEEL TWO OF YOU
ARE STEADILY IMPROVING,
BUT ONE OF YOU JUST DOESN'T
MAKE THE GRADE RIGHT NOW.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
NAIMA.
CONGRATULATIONS, NAIMA.
YOU STARTED OFF AS THE GIRL
THAT HAD EVERYTHING TO HIDE
AND WAS TRYING TO HIDE
EVEN FROM HERSELF.
BUT YOU OPENED UP THE DOOR
TO YOUR HEART
AND TO YOUR SPIRIT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ARE A FINALIST.
THANK YOU.
WILL KEENYAH AND KAHLEN
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL BE
THE FINALIST
AND WILL COMPETE WITH NAIMA
IN AN AMAZING FASHION SHOW.
I WILL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL I DO NOT CALL
HAS TO GO.
KEENYAH, KAHLEN, I WANT YOU
TO FACE EACH OTHER RIGHT NOW.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK
AT EACH OTHER.
KAHLEN, KEENYAH HAS EVERYTHING
THAT YOU NEED.
SHE HAS SPARKLE.
SHE HAS SPUNK.
WHEN SHE WALKS INTO THE ROOM,
SHE DEMANDS ATTENTION,
BECAUSE SHE HAS SOME HIGH
SELF-ESTEEM AND THAT MAKES
AN AMAZING SPOKESMODEL.
KEENYAH, I WANT YOU
TO LOOK AT KAHLEN.
WHAT SHE HAS, YOU NEED.
SHE CAN POSE HER ASS OFF
IN A PHOTO.
SHE CAN EVOKE ANY EMOTION
THAT IS DEMANDED,
HAS A PRESENCE ON THE RUNWAY
THAT IS SO SIMILAR TO THE TOP
MODELS WORKING THE RUNWAY TODAY.
THE JUDGES DEBATED A LOT
TONIGHT.
ONE OF YOU HAS MORE POTENTIAL
THAN THE OTHER ONE.
ONE OF YOU IS STRONGER.
ONE OF YOU IS A FINALIST.
ONE OF YOU HAS MORE
POTENTIAL THAN THE OTHER ONE.
ONE OF YOU IS STRONGER.
I ALREADY HAVE
THIS CONFIDENCE AND THIS BACK UP
THAT I DID REALLY GOOD
ON THE COMMERCIAL, SO I FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT MYSELF.
IT IS SCARY FOR ME.
I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME,
BUT I THINK I AM.
ONE OF YOU IS A FINALIST.
YOU WILL COMPETE WITH NAIMA
IN AN AMAZING FASHION SHOW.
KAHLEN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE A FINALIST.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
I HONESTLY AM
A LITTLE BIT SHOCKED.
BECAUSE RIGHT BEFORE
SHE CALLED THE NAME,
SHE SAID THAT ONE OF YOU HAS
MORE POTENTIAL THAN THE OTHER
AND THAT ONE OF YOU IS STRONGER.
AND I THOUGHT
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT ME.
I REALLY WANTED TO BE
ONE OF THE LAST TWO,
AND I REALLY THOUGHT THAT I
HAD MORE POTENTIAL THAN KAHLEN.
I THINK HIGHLY OF MYSELF.
I REALLY THOUGHT
THAT IT WAS GONNA BE ME.
I'M GONNA TAKE
ALL THE JUDGES' ADVICE AS IF I'M
STILL GONNA BE THE WINNER
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
NOTHING'S GONNA HOLD ME BACK
UNLESS I GET FATTER.
ME AND NAIMA WERE GOING UP
TO THE TOP OF TABLE MOUNTAIN.
I FEEL LIKE I'M IN HEAVEN.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED,
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT I WOULD
HAVE MADE IT TO THE FINAL TWO.
HEY, NAIMA,
THERE'S THE HOTEL.
CAN YOU SEE IT, REALLY?
NO.
I'VE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF KAHLEN, AND KAHLEN
HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ME.
BUT RIGHT NOW,
KAHLEN IS NOT MY FRIEND.
SHE'S A GIRL I HAVE TO OUTSHINE.
I'VE GOTTA DO BETTER THAN HER--
BOTTOM LINE.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE NAIMA
IN THE FINAL COMPETITION.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THAT, YOU KNOW, PUSHES ME HARDER
OR CHALLENGES ME MORE.
BUT THIS IS A COMPETITION
AND I'M HERE TO BEAT NAIMA.
I'VE VISITED
A PIECE OF HEAVEN, AND I'M READY
TO GO BACK TO THE EARTH.
I'M READY FOR THE RUNWAY.
HEY.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
HI, MR. JAY.
HI, JAY.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS FEELING?
GOOD.
BUTTERFLIES.
BUTTERFLIES?
WE HAVE CREATED
THE MOST EXCITING FASHION SHOW.
THREE DESIGNERS ARE GONNA BE
FEATURED IN TONIGHT'S SHOW--
POISON IVY,
GAVIN RAJAH
AND RUBY.
OF COURSE, THERE'S GONNA BE
A FULL AUDIENCE,
SO IT'S A BIG EVENT.
YOU GUYS HAVE TO BE THE STARS
OF THIS EVENT.
I'M SO READY FOR THIS MOMENT.
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS ENTIRE COMPETITION.
BUT NOW I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
WHAT WE'VE CREATED.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M EXPECTING A LONG RUNWAY
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WALK
TO THE END, POSE.
WE'RE GONNA GO UP HERE.
THIS WHOLE ENVIRONMENT AT NIGHT
IS GONNA BE DARK.
THERE ARE ALL THESE LIGHTS
THAT ARE GONNA BE MOVING AROUND.
I DON'T SEE THE RUNWAY.
I CAN'T SEE IT,
AND I HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THE RAMP IS.
NO IDEA.
AND I'M REALLY CONFUSED.
WE'RE WALKING ON WATER?
OH, MY GOD.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING
ON WATER.
EXACTLY.
YOU CAN KIND OF SEE THE RUNWAY
IN THE WATER RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN KIND OF SEE
A BLACK PLANK
CIRCLING THE FOUNTAIN.
AND I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
THIS IS RIDICULOUS."
WHOO!
YOU MODEL TRAMPS
NEED TO STOMP
AND MAKE THIS WATER
DO THE WATER DANCE
IF IT'S THE LAST THING
THAT YOU DO.
WE ARE WALKING ON WATER
LIKE DIVAS, ALL RIGHT?
WALK LIKE JESUS.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW
IF JESUS HAD THE SAME KIND
OF HIP ACTION.
HE HAD IT, IT WAS JUST
UNDER THE ROBE, BABY.
CAN ANY OF YOU SWIM?
I WAS LIKE, "UH-OH, I'M GOING
TO BE THE ONE THAT FALLS."
I'M REALLY NERVOUS
BECAUSE IT'S WATER,
BUT I AM EXCITED AS ALL HELL
ABOUT THIS SHOW.
I'VE NEVER BEEN
IN A FASHION SHOW.
I'VE NEVER WALKED
DOWN THE RUNWAY, EXCEPT FOR WHEN
MY MOM'S COOKING DINNER AND I'M
WALKING UP AND DOWN THE HALLWAY
GOING--
HELLO, HELLO, HELLO.
NERVOUS?
I HAVE BUTTERFLIES.
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING THAT I
HAVE NEVER DONE IN MY LIFE.
I HAVE NEVER WALKED
ON A RUNWAY UNDER WATER.
WHENEVER YOU DO A SWIMSUIT
OR A LINGERIE FASHION SHOW,
AS SOON AS YOU GET THERE,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO TAKE
ALL YOUR CLOTHES OFF
SO THE LINES GO AWAY.
DON'T BE NERVOUS.
THE JUDGES ARE GONNA BE
YELLING YOU NAME.
DO NOT
LOOK AT US, KEEP FORWARD.
YOU KEEP STRONG,
AND YOU WORK IT.
BACKSTAGE THERE'S TONS
OF PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND
GOING CRAZY, GETTING READY
FOR THE SHOW.
I THINK
THAT IF I'M TALKING TO NAIMA
RIGHT BEFORE THE RUNWAY SHOW,
I'M GONNA LOSE MY FOCUS.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO BE
DISTRACTED BY KAHLEN.
I JUST WANT TO FOCUS ON MYSELF
AND BE TOTALLY PREPARED
FOR THE LAST CHALLENGE.
YOU GUYS ALL
LOOK AMAZING.
BUT I WANT TO REMIND YOU GUYS,
IT'S DARK NOW.
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO FALL OFF THE RUNWAY.
GOT THE WALK, NOT TOO MUCH--
EVERY GIRL ON THAT RUNWAY
IS MY COMPETITION--
EVERY GIRL.
SO I HAVE TO STAND OUT
FROM EVERYONE,
NOT JUST FROM KAHLEN.
I LIKE THE UPRIGHT,
BUT DON'T LET IT GET LOCKED.
TONIGHT DECIDES ME
AND NAIMA'S FATE.
ONLY ONE OF US CAN WIN.
THERE'S TWO OF US LEFT.
ONE OF US WILL WIN,
ONE OF US WILL LOSE.
OKAY, AND FIVE,
FOUR, THREE, TWO...
LET'S GIVE THEM A SHOW.
GIVE THEM A SHOW.
I'M READY.
ALL I AM THINKING IS
AM I GONNA FALL OFF THAT RUNWAY?
BECAUSE I'M A LITTLE CLUMSY,
AND I'M JUST GONNA SLIDE
RIGHT OFF.
ALL RIGHT, GIRLS,
LET'S WORK IT OUT!
I'M STANDING IN LINE.
I'M WAITING.
I'VE GOT ANXIETY.
I'VE GOT BUTTERFLIES.
I'M JUST LIKE,
"OKAY LET'S GO.
LET'S GET THIS ON."
OKAY, IN FIVE, FOUR,
THREE, TWO,
CUE MUSIC!
WORK IT!
COME ON, NAIMA,
THIS IS YOUR TIME.
GIVE ME A HIGH-FIVE, GIRL.
I CAN GLANCE DOWN
AND SEE MY FEET STOMPING
THROUGH THE WATER.
I FEEL SUPERHUMAN.
LET'S GO, KAHLEN.
LET'S GO.
WORK IT OUT.
THAT'S MY GIRL.
THAT'S MY GIRL!
I HIT THAT FIRST POSE
AND I FEEL THIS
JUST HUGE ADRENALIN RUSH.
AND I CAN FEEL MY HEART
GETTING READY TO EXPLODE.
THAT LOOKS AWESOME.
I NEED SOME EVENING
GOWNS COMING UP.
THE SCENE BACKSTAGE
IS JUST COMPLETE CHAOS.
WHY IS THAT TAKING SO LONG?
I CAN KIND OF
SEE THE JUDGES.
I HEAR THEM SCREAMING.
COME ON, KAHLEN!
WORK IT OUT!
NOT ONLY AM I STOMPING
ON ALL THOSE PEOPLE
THAT DIDN'T BELIEVE IN ME,
I'M STOMPING ON THAT GIRL
THAT DOESN'T BELIEVE IN HERSELF.
THIS IS YOUR
LAST PASS GIRLS.
THIS IS THE BIG WALK.
THIS IS THE ONE WHERE THE JUDGES
ARE GONNA BE COMPARING US
TO EACH OTHER.
I'M GONNA NEED NAIMA
AND KAHLEN RIGHT NEXT TO ME.
I'M GONNA WALK DOWN
THAT RUNWAY
AND LOOK KAHLEN DEAD IN THE EYE
AND SAY, "LOOK, BITCH,
THIS IS WHAT I HAVE TO OFFER."
♪♪♪
THIS IS GONNA BE THE FINALE!
SMILE, CLAP.
LET'S GO.
I'M SO OVERCOME WITH EVERY
SINGLE EMOTION THAT LAST WALK
THAT I CAN'T EVEN HOLD A BEAT
WHEN I'M CLAPPING.
AMAZING!
THAT WAS AMAZING.
YOU GIRLS ROCKED!
DO YOU WANT A HUG?
NO, I DON'T WANT A HUG.
YOU GIRLS WORKED IT OUT.
GOOD JOB, GOOD JOB,
GOOD JOB.
CAN WE GET THEM A TOWEL?
THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
MY GOD.
GIVE ME SOME LOVE!
AND ALL OF THAT IN THE END,
YOU GUYS!
AND ALL OF THAT WATER.
THEY DID
A GOOD JOB, RIGHT?
I'M PROUD.
GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
I'M VERY PROUD.
MAMA'S PROUD.
NOW WE CAN BE FRIENDS AGAIN.
TO OUR FIRST FASHION SHOW,
ALWAYS IN OUR MEMORIES.
OVERALL IN THIS COMPETITION,
I THINK I ROCKED.
I REALLY DO.
I THINK KAHLEN HAS
A LOT OF NATURAL ABILITY
THAT I DON'T HAVE.
BUT I FELT LIKE
I WAS THE STAR OF THAT SHOW.
TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES,
ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
KAHLEN, YOU ARE THE GREATEST
MODEL IN THE WORLD.
NAIMA, YOUR WALK TONIGHT
WAS BEAUTIFUL.
WELCOME, LADIES.
TODAY IS A VERY SPECIAL
JUDGING DAY, ISN'T IT?
IT'S THE FINAL JUDGING DAY.
WE ARE GONNA DECIDE WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU GUYS HAVE COME
A LONG, LONG WAY--
ONE GIRL FROM DETROIT, MICHIGAN,
AND THE OTHER FROM OKLAHOMA!
BUT NOW IT IS TIME FOR YOU ALL
TO TAKE EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE TAUGHT YOU
AND GRADUATE INTO THE REAL WORLD
OF MODELING
AS AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW, OF COURSE, YOU GUYS HAVE
BEEN HEARING ABOUT THE FABULOUS
PRIZES FOR WEEKS ON END.
BUT TONIGHT THEY'RE REAL
AND THEY'RE TANGIBLE,
BECAUSE ONE OF YOU
IS GONNA WALK AWAY WITH THEM.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL MODEL
MANAGEMENT COMPANY--
FORD MODELS--
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BESIMON
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AS YOU GUYS CAN SEE TONIGHT,
THERE IS NO GUEST JUDGE.
BECAUSE WHO KNOWS YOU BETTER
BUT US FOUR?
THE FIRST JUDGE
JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS,
NIGEL BARKER
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
NOLé MARIN PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR EVALUATIONS.
THEN THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
THEN WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH OF YOU SHOULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU GUYS HAD TO COMPETE
IN A FASHION SHOW.
NAIMA, CAME OUT FIRST
AND HERE SHE IS.
YOU SCARED ME WHEN YOU CAME OUT
BUT IN A GOOD WAY.
LIKE, I WAS IN SHOCK.
I WAS IN AWE.
I WAS LIKE, "IS THAT BEYONCE
MORPHED INTO A TOP MODEL?"
KAHLEN'S FIRST PASSAGE.
THAT'S SO GREAT.
YOU LOOK LIKE MODELS.
WHEN YOU STARTED WALKING,
I THOUGHT YOU WERE FIERCE.
I FELT THE STOMP.
YOU ABSOLUTELY HAD
THE GALLIANO WALK FROM PARIS.
NAIMA,
YOU COMMANDED THAT RUNWAY.
IT WAS JUST FLAWLESS.
IT LOOKED LIKE A VERSACE SHOW.
KAHLEN, YOUR MOUTH
WOULD GET REALLY TENSE WITH IT
AND YOUR NECK GETS REALLY STIFF.
TRUTH OF THE MATTER,
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A BETTER
BATHING-SUIT PROPORTIONED BODY
TO NAIMA'S.
YOU GUYS WERE FABULOUS.
I AM SO PROUD
OF BOTH OF YOU.
SO YOU GUYS HAVE HAD A LOT
OF PHOTO SHOOTS AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GONNA COMPARE THEM--
KAHLEN'S PHOTO
VERSUS NAIMA'S PHOTO--
STARTING WITH WEEK ONE,
WHERE WE MADE YOU ALIENS.
NOW I REMEMBER
SHOOTING BOTH OF YOU GIRLS.
YOU WERE TWO OF MY FAVORITES--
DIFFERENT,
BUT BOTH VERY INTERESTING.
NEXT SHOOT,
YOU POSED WITH A LOT OF DOGS.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT YOU KAHLEN
IS YOUR MOUTH.
A LOT OF MODELS IN THE '70s
HAD THAT THAT TYPE OF, LIKE,
KIND OF POUTY MOUTH.
NAIMA'S SHOT.
IT IS A MEDIOCRE SHOT.
THE MOHAWK I FEEL WENT OUT
IN THE LATE '90s.
SO THIS PHOTO SHOOT
WAS DEALING WITH THE ELEMENTS--
WITH WIND AND RAIN.
VERY SEXY PICTURE,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A LOT OF GUYS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO PIN THIS UP
ON THEIR WALL.
NAIMA'S SHOT.
I LIKE THE TOMBOY-ESQUENESS
OF IT, THAT'S IT'S SEXY,
BUT IT'S, I'M GONNA BEAT YOUR
BUTT, TOO, AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS PHOTO SHOOT
WAS SEVEN DEADLY SINS.
NAIMA WAS ENVY
AND KAHLEN WAS WRATH!
LOVE, LOVE, LOVE.
FLAWLESS.
YOU LOOK IT UP
IN THE DICTIONARY WRATH,
THIS IS WHAT YOU WOULD SEE.
NAIMA'S SHOT.
I JUST THINK YOU COULD HAVE
DONE MORE WITH YOUR FACE.
KAHLEN PULLED IT OUT MORE.
WELCOME
TO WILD KINGDOM, LADIES.
THESE SHOTS WERE FABULOUS.
KAHLEN, YOU ARE A SPRINGBOK
IN THIS PICTURE,
THE ESSENCE OF A WILD ANIMAL.
YOU NAILED THIS PICTURE.
NAIMA'S SHOT.
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WE'VE HAD TWO GIRLS IN THE PAST
THAT WERE DANCERS,
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO BREAK THEM
FROM LOOKING LIKE A DANCER,
AND YOU KNOW HOW
TO BALANCE IT SO WELL.
NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
THIS WAS KIND OF LIKE
AN AFRICAN PARTY.
NAIMA'S PHOTO FIRST.
THE BODY LANGUAGE
IS FANTASTIC.
YOU WERE THE STAR OF THAT PHOTO.
THIS IS YOUR BEST HEAD SHOT.
KIND OF LOOKED LIKE YOU WERE
DANCING ALL NIGHT LONG
AND YOU DIDN'T TAKE A BREAK.
SO THIS NEXT WEEK'S
PHOTO SHOOT WAS A COVER GIRL
PHOTO SHOOT.
THE WINNER OF THE COMPETITION,
THIS IS GONNA BE YOUR AD
THAT'S GONNA RUN
IN NATIONAL MAGAZINES.
I READ EVERY MAGAZINE,
AND I WOULD STOP
AT THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
NAIMA'S SHOT.
THIS IS THE COVER GIRL SHOT
FOR ME.
HOWEVER, I DON'T LIKE
THIS PICTURE AS MUCH
AS KAHLEN'S PICTURE.
TELL ME, KAHLEN,
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU SHOULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
'CAUSE I THINK I'VE OVERCOME
SO MUCH OF WHO I AM.
I'VE OVERCOME
SITTING IN THE CORNER
AND NOT BEING THAT PRETTY GIRL
AND BEING OVERLOOKED
TIME AND TIME AGAIN
AND NEVER BEING GOOD ENOUGH.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, NAIMA,
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU SHOULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
IT'S OKAY.
I HATED MYSELF.
I HATED THIS GIRL.
THAT WAS MY LOWEST POINT, TYRA.
I WALKED IN HERE TODAY
AND I FELT BEAUTIFUL.
YOU GUYS ARE PROOF
THAT MODELS AREN'T SHELLS.
THAT THEY ARE TRUE PEOPLE
WITH FEELINGS AND EMOTIONS
AND PASTS AND INSECURITIES,
BEAUTIFUL FROM THE INSIDE OUT.
AND YOU'RE PROVING THAT
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
SO WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'M GONNA ANNOUNCE WHO'S GONNA
BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SO WE HAVE
TWO PORTFOLIOS HERE
AND TWO VERY STRONG CANDIDATES.
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN--
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
YOU KNOW, PHOTOGRAPHICALLY
KAHLEN'S DONE AN AMAZING JOB.
KAHLEN DEFINITELY
IS PHOTOGENIC, BUT IN PERSON,
SHE JUST LOOKS DRY.
THIS IS WHAT THE PROS DO,
EVERYBODY.
EACH PHOTOGRAPH
SHOWS A DIFFERENT SIDE
OF VERSATILITY.
I CAN CALL UP ANY ONE
ONE OF THESE AGENCIES SAYING I
WANT A BLONDE CASTING AND GET
LOTS OF GIRLS WITH GOOD WORKING
PORTFOLIOS WHO ARE BLONDE.
I THINK YOU'RE BEING A LITTLE
BIT STEREOTYPICAL SAYING
SHE'S JUST A BLONDE-HAIRED,
BLUE-EYED GIRL.
KAHLEN HAS SOMETHING SPECIAL.
SHE'S AN EDGY BLONDE-HAIR,
BLUE-EYED GIRL.
KAHLEN'S BODY PROPORTIONS
ARE PERFECT
FOR A DESIGNER'S MUSE.
I WAS VERSACE'S MUSE.
I WAS VALENTINO'S MUSE.
I DON'T KNOW
WHY YOU'RE LAUGHING.
I DON'T KNOW WHOSE MUSE
YOU WERE.
IN THE FASHION SHOW,
NAIMA ROCKED IT.
SHE WAS SO AMAZING.
I STILL HAVE CHILLS
JUST THINKING ABOUT IT.
IT'S QUITE EVIDENT
IN THE SHOW
THAT NAIMA RULED THE SHOW.
SHE HAS STAGE PRESENCE.
THAT'S IN YOUR OPINION.
KAHLEN HAS A BETTER
BODY OF WORK FROM WEEK TO WEEK.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE FINAL EXAMS--
THE COVER GIRL SHOOT,
THE COMMERCIAL
AND THE FASHION SHOW--
NAIMA WINS HANDS DOWN.
AT THE SAME TIME, I'M VERY
INSPIRED BY KAHLEN'S PHOTOS.
I THINK SHE ROCKS A PHOTO.
KAHLEN HAS GIVEN TOP MODEL
ONE OF THEIR BEST PORTFOLIOS.
AS JUDGES, WHAT DO WE CHOOSE,
THE GIRL THAT DID GOOD
ALL SEMESTER AND KIND OF FAILED
IN FINAL EXAMS,
OR THE GIRL THAT DID FAIR
DURING THE SEMESTER
AND KILLED IN THE FINAL EXAMS?
I AM SO CONFUSED,
BECAUSE--OH!
HI, LADIES.
THIS IS THE END OF
THE JOURNEY.
YOU GUYS HAVE COME SO FAR.
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU CAN BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE FEEL ONLY ONE OF YOU
HAS WHAT IT TAKES
TO ENTER THE FASHION INDUSTRY
AND COMPETE AGAINST
SOME OF MY PEERS.
YOUR JOURNEYS
HAVE BEEN VERY DIFFERENT.
NAIMA, YOUR JOURNEY WAS GOOD,
AND IT WAS STRONG,
AND IT WAS SOLID.
BUT WHEN WE REVIEWED
YOUR PORTFOLIO,
IT WASN'T GREAT.
BUT FOR YOUR FINAL EXAM,
YOU TURNED IT OUT.
YOU HAD PRESENCE.
YOU HAD AN AURA THAT SPEAKS
TO A LOT OF YOUNG GIRLS
IN AMERICA.
AND IN THE FINAL FASHION SHOW,
YOU ROCKED.
KAHLEN, YOU TAKE PICTURES
THAT ARE SO GORGEOUS
THEY RIVAL THE TOP MODELS
THAT ARE IN "ELLE," "VOGUE"
AND "HARPERS BAZAAR" RIGHT NOW.
BUT IN YOUR FINAL EXAM,
YOU WERE STRONG.
YOU WERE SOLID,
BUT YOU DIDN'T OWN
THAT FASHION SHOW.
THIS WAS THE LONGEST
DELIBERATION WE'VE EVER DONE.
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
IS...
NAIMA.
OH!
I'M SPEECHLESS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GIVE ME A HUG.
YOU DID SO GOOD.
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
WHEN I SET FOOT
ON THAT RUNWAY,
IT MADE ME REALIZE
WHY I WANTED TO DO THIS.
THAT ADRENALINE AND EVERY
EMOTION THAT WAS RUNNING THROUGH
MY BODY, THAT'S WHY
I WANT TO DO THIS.
THAT'S WHY I'VE DREAMT ABOUT IT
FOR SO LONG.
I FEEL LIKE MODELING IS MY WAY
OF EXPRESSING MY EMOTIONS.
AND IT TOOK THIS COMPETITION
TO REALLY OPEN MY EYES.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOUNG LADY.
I WAS FORCED TO LOOK INSIDE
NAIMA AND SEE WHAT IT IS
THAT MAKES ME, ME,
THAT MAKES ME BEAUTIFUL.
AND I FOUND IT.
UNIQUELY VERSATILE
UNDENIABLY EDGY--
NAIMA, THE SPUNKY DETROIT GIRL
EMBODIES A TRUE COVER GIRL.
I AM A COVER GIRL--
A REAL LIVE FASHION MODEL.
IT'S TAKEN SO MUCH
TO GET HERE.
IT HAS TAKEN SO MUCH.
YOU'RE A GORGEOUS WOMAN.
KNOCK 'EM DEAD, BABY.
PART OF THE REASON
THAT I FELT I HAD TO WIN THIS
WAS BECAUSE I REPRESENT
SOMETHING MORE THAN MYSELF.
I REPRESENT A BLACK GIRL.
I REPRESENT
A MEXICAN GIRL.
I'M PART IRISH.
I'M EVERYTHING.
I'M AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
OH, MY GOD!